right now young women are really putting
their foot down and saying these are our
bodies so we don't really care what you
you know 45 year old mom and the suburbs
think his consent and we don't care what
you 55 year old college president think
his consent these are our bodies and
this is what is leasing from the
conviction of Vanderbilt University
football players for raping an
unconscious student to the he-said
she-said story behind Columbia
University's mattress girl to the
discredited Rolling Stone account of a
gang rape at the University of Virginia
few topics generate more emotion and
outrage than sexual assault on college
campuses
Vanessa grigory Otis is a national
magazine award-winning journalist and
the author of the new book blurred lines
rethinking sex power and consent on
campus millennial college students are
actually having less sex than their
baby-boomer counterparts did brights
grigory artists but today's encounters
take place in a hyper sexualized and
pornified social media context that has
rewritten the rules of consent and
privacy the result is confusion and
recriminations from all sides when it
comes to sex and assault on campuses our
assault rates and rape culture out of
control where have we entered what
left-wing Northwestern professor Laura
Kipnis has called a new era of sexual
McCarthyism I talked to gregorio
disavowed all this and more in reasons
new york studio Vanessa thanks for
talking thank you for having me your
book is not only richly reported it's
filled with interviews with dozens if
not hundreds of students administrators
researchers it's a deeply nuanced to
look at a subject that typically if
folks really sharply polarized positions
but you write it's tempting to chant
believe women and simply leave it at
that but there's a mushy middle here or
a blurry middle describe what you mean
by that mushy metal or blurry metal I
went to 20 campuses I talked to students
themselves tried to interact as a peer
not as an adult coming asking weird
intrusive questions right I'm kind of a
gonzo journalist out of the rolling
stone mold I put on a backpack
look relatively young not like a Gen X
mother of two which is what I actually
am and went to campus food courts went
to frat parties you know I took my
babysitter's ID she's 24 years old so I
would take that with me to campuses so I
could show that to bouncers at like
college bars and at frat parties to get
in so that you know the person wouldn't
think that I was using like the worst
fake ID in the world of my actual age in
the 1970s so I spoke with these students
and what I learned is yes of course
there is rape on campus and I'm talking
about physically violent rape where
women's will is over ridden and also
rape of you know women and men who are
passed out from drinking right almost
like a necrophilia kind of thing I mean
it's really repulsive but much more
often what I was finding people kids
talking to me about cases that were
blurry and they weren't blurry in terms
of the way we might have once thought
about sexual assault where a woman just
kind of protests and says no no no but
the guy you know knows that she this is
just a foe right I mean it's not the
Hollywood fantasy of the 40s or even the
six years of where no no no and then you
know the kiss and they dissolves into a
marriage senior's right exactly I mean
these are genuinely cases of I mean
apart from the the clear cases of
assault there are things where everybody
is unclear about exactly what transpired
sure these are cases about misconstrued
consent right and nobody watching this
you and I probably do not have the same
definition of consent there is no
nationwide definition there's not even a
millennial definition but right now
young women are really putting their
foot down and saying these are our
bodies and we want a new definition and
we're driving this train so we don't
really care what you you know 45 year
old mom and the suburbs think is consent
and we don't care what you 55 year old
college
president think is consent these are our
bodies and this is what we say what is
driving that sense of of what you found
you know a real sense of empowerment you
know there's an assistance there there's
not always a radical coherence or but
you know what is driving that sense of
look these are our bodies and we're
gonna do with them
you know we control them nobody else
does I mean I think it's part of the
radicalism that spread on campus right
starting in you know a couple of years
ago but actually even a bit further back
and even further back than that when
Obama was elected there was an immediate
rise of these female pop stars like
Beyonce and Rihanna and Katy Perry and
Taylor Swift in all of these non
manufactured stars whose message is one
message and it's girl power and it's
girls are in control and it's I'm may
stand here in a bikini singing my song
but I'm objectifying myself and I will
always be in control sexually and
professionally and in the home this is
the time for girls to rule and there's a
whole edifice of female centric media
from Jezebel to bustle to even Cosmo
today that are purveyors of the most
radical feminist thought that I have
heard outside of 1977 and but in that
it's also it contravenes a lot of more
traditional feminism in terms of you
know it's it's highly sexualized in a
lot of ways that at various points going
back to you know whether it's Simone de
Beauvoir or you know Gloria Steinem or
Betty Ford and I mean this is a highly
sexualized highly public perspective
that even a lot of older feminists are
uncomfortable with but is that one of
the sources of confusion because men you
know men or boys see that one I mean
even some women see it one way even men
and boys see it another way so what what
has happened concurrently with
millennial boys because they're they're
growing up in the same world they're
growing up in a world of kind of public
privacy almost or where the body is much
more displayed in also forms why aren't
they getting the message
the girls are sentient look this is a
very confusing moment okay we have kids
today who are just like they're
searching for likes that's all they're
doing all day they're putting pictures
up I mean it's completely visually based
culture now right it's Instagram and
snapchat all the time and those pictures
they want attention for them and the
best way to get attention if you're a
girl is to put up a provocative photo if
you show some flesh you're gonna get a
lot of likes if you're a college
freshman girl you know that right this
is happening at the same time when
almost a pornified look is what we see
among our reality stars it's what we see
TV anchors who are female outside of
candy crowley can't even be on TV unless
they're in a tank top right so I mean
there's no question that the standard
for the sexualization of the female in
the public eye you know and everybody's
in the public eye now right has just
risen astronomically and I'm not gonna
say sit here and say the boys who are
growing up in a time an American culture
that has taught them that girls who look
[ __ ] may also be [ __ ] right that
when girls look a certain way it means
that they may be offering something
sexually are not going to be confused by
this intensely sexualized and
sex-positive moment because these girls
in addition to sexualizing themselves
are trying to also foster within
themselves a female sexual empowerment a
feeling that this is my body
boys stay away until I tell you what you
can do obviously the book is partly
about both women talking about that and
they're confused by it as well as as
well as boys or men on campus you know
your book begins and ends with a
discussion of what's probably the most
publicized story of the past several
years about sex and assault on campus
the 2013 case involving Columbia
students emma silhouettes and paul
Nungesser selca wits accused Nungesser
afraid during an encounter that they
both agree began as consensual he was
cleared of wrongdoing by
campus hearing she protested that by
carrying a mattress as part of an art
project around for her entire senior
year including the graduation just a few
weeks ago Nungesser received the
confidential settlement from Columbia
University which he brought under Title
9 the you know the gender equity
statement saying that they had failed to
provide a welcoming environment for him
they have subjected him to harassment
based on gender terms why is that case
emblematic of you know of the blurred
lines okay well you know first of all
what happened between Emma and Paul what
she alleges is that they had had oral
sex they had had vaginal sex and it
escalated to anal sex which you know
they had perhaps had before and at that
point it became rape now not everybody
in America agrees that once you're in
the bed and you've done some intercourse
that anything else that happens there is
not fair game right I mean I don't agree
with that but the fact is is that many
Americans would feel that way so that
was the first thing that was complicated
about her story the second thing is is
that on an evidence tip you know like
many of these cases there's really no
evidence to be had here you know we
don't have the you know the the photos
that demonstrate exactly what he did you
know we don't really know in the end and
what you think about that case probably
has a lot to do with your own feeling
about what should constitute sexual
assault what is a fair standard of
evidence right if we know she doesn't
have much then what did Columbia really
do wrong well I mean one thing that
Nungesser alleged was that at the
initial hearings he was not allowed to
provide evidence exculpatory evidence
emails text messages Facebook messages
things like that and I and you know what
what I'm getting at is you know there's
her side and that raises you know both
in terms of her narrative which he
either challenges or not but then is the
you know is it also a is it a case not
simple
about sexual assault but also about due
process and and whether or not these
things should be adjudicated on campus
or you know and nobody would say if
there was a murder on campus that you
would say okay well we'll have you know
we'll get a bunch of faculty member as a
student representative and you know an
administrator to try that case so I mean
there are multiple ways in which this is
kind of a blurry issue right well okay
you know when Emma got attacked for not
taking her case to the cops which a lot
of New York media said well why didn't
you do that she went to the car she did
file a police report
right so why are we so sure that the
police who have historically had a
terrible record with rape and let's
remember we are talking about date rape
here for the most part right we are not
talking about blood and bruises and
physical evidence the vagina is built to
have a baby come out of it there has to
be a hell of a lot of force going on
right and even when there is a hell of a
force there's not always physical
evidence that's why the cops don't want
anything to do with this the prosecutors
know that some weird college case that's
about consent is one real hot political
potato and they they don't want hot
potato they don't want anything to do
with that so to me this is is really you
know just a red herring in this whole
conversation because we know they're not
gonna take care of it at least in the
short term maybe down the line and the
police will get better etc but right now
what we're talking about is new sexual
standards new standards of sexual ethics
and the universities can be involved
secondly the case with Emma and Paul
took place at Columbia I want to say
that was 2013 that was four years ago
there's been a vast change on campuses
with the amount of money that they've
put into these kinds of departments the
training that they've given to their
officers Columbia now supplies attorneys
on both sides
okay des Vosges said all of this
mumbo-jumbo about how these cases nobody
even knows what the charges are against
them and ba-ba-ba-ba-ba
I don't think that's the case not at our
prestigious universities anymore I mean
universities would have to have a death
wish to not be upholding due process in
campus sexual assault cases at this
point but they know the press is coming
after them they know they're gonna get
litigated you know they're getting an is
that a bad and that's office of civil
rights is that a bad outcome in terms of
process because it does seem I mean
there are many cases that get reported
you know where due process is pretty
sloppy including people like Laura
Kipnis who's you know a professor at
Northwestern who had a case where a
hostile workplace case under title 9 was
brought against her because of an
article she had written in The Chronicle
of Higher Education by grad students she
in her book a recent book she you know
she was not allowed to have any kind of
representation so and I agree it's it's
a moving you know it's it's it's
shifting constantly but I mean it seems
you're kind of skeptical about due
process claims I'm not skeptical that
due process has not been abrogated in
some of these cases but what I think
people should understand is universities
are getting better all the time
at handling these cases they also need
to understand that universities are
bound by the federal privacy regulations
that do not allow them to comment on any
individual case thereby when you read
something about there being an
investigation right from OCR or will we
see much more often now are the
complaints from the accused boys being
posted by their lawyers being posted on
document cloud that is just the accused
boys story I didn't hear the girls part
it didn't get that far in the court yet
right and the article that says OCR is
investigating you know Wesleyan
University or whatever that one never
has the come back from the university
the university will never be able to
speak on what they actually think
happened with Emma and Paul
they'll never speak
on what happened you know we do know
though that I mean they found him
innocent of the charges so I mean there
is that which would also be like so he
got a settlement what was that
settlement they already found him
innocent so you know that seems to me to
be more media manipulation of the story
you know I'm not saying that what
happened at Columbia in 2013 with Emma
and Paul's case was good because I don't
think it was okay I think Columbia was
acting very sloppily back then but I
think they've changed and I think a lot
of universities have changed and they're
not getting their due here well yeah I
guess the press is always lagging in in
that sense or people pick up on stories
well let's talk a little bit about the
reality of sex on campus first in terms
of actual activity or sexual activity
and then in terms of assault because one
of the things your book which is is
fascinating and is I don't want to say
even hand it because that seems like you
know it's you know on the one hand on
the other but it's you know you you look
at what's going on what sexual activity
and this is something every older
generation or the minute that you
graduate from college you assume that
the freshmen are having tons more sex
and better sex or weird sex and all of
that but also then as you get older
you're like oh my god they you know
they're it's it's beyond animal it's
like Animal House and Thunderdome what's
going on you know in terms of rates of
sex among today's college students as
well as rates of assault
okay so rates of sex and rates of sexual
assault don't seem to really be up right
the average student has eight hookups
over the course of college and that can
be any sort of sexual activity so that's
like from a make-out session to to
intercourse exactly so you know 20
percent of college students graduate as
virgins so they're certainly not as much
that's interesting because only 8%
showed up at college as virgins right
exactly so you know the fact is that
what's really going on is early sexual
experiences and these aren't really
sexual experiences right the average age
I think is 17 of losing your virginity
and there's something that is radically
changed from the bay
boom through now you know a higher rates
of people graduate high school without
having sexual experience etc so and we
know that the more the kids are on their
phones the last well in your life her
shoe her shoe Alexander Graham Bell
Steve Jobs with the hand is now the
central relationship in fact in my day
the relationship with the hand was also
centralized no phone we're going circle
you know the issue is is that these
early sexual experiences are including
assault and that's what we need to talk
about right we need to understand that
there are guys who are you know I'm
particularly you know gonna talk about
guys are pushing both men and women into
sex that those you know those people do
not want to have and whether they're
holding a hand behind that victim's back
or they're taking advantage of a student
who's barely speaking English by that
you mean because they're drunk cuz
they're wrong they're so drunk you know
and that's just that's not cool that's
where I think the change is coming is
they students are saying look that girl
she was wearing beer goggles you took
her home you're not getting a high five
in the morning and other girls are gonna
call that guy creepy they may even call
him a rapist right and they're gonna
spread that all over campus and make
sure that that guy has a bad name and
now other guys are watching what
happened to that first guy and damn
straight they don't want that to happen
to them you know and that is truly
happening on campus how do you kind of
moderate the or kind of go from the
definitions of what one person's creepy
is another person's you know completely
anodyne compliment like you know out on
the street if some guy says hey baby to
me I may say screw you get away from me
and somebody else may say thank you you
know that made my day
you know low-level acts of of you know
that's not even really harassment right
that's like a cos treat compliment
whatever you know but it's not like a
hiss is so great or somebody yelling
[ __ ] at you on the street is so great
and those kinds of low-level acts that
happen at college all the time like
somebody's squeezing a girl's ass in a
frat house or you know just feeling up a
girl on the couch who you happen to be
sitting next to in the common room
because she's wearing a parka and you
know you could slip your hand under
there and she's probably not going to
say or do something like I would call
that stuff creepy right and all guys out
for it but young girls are calling that
sexual assault you know one of the the
great virtues of the book is the number
of students should talk to particularly
women on campus and and that incident
you're talking about with a woman who
was wearing a parka and a guy
essentially assaulted her he groped her
vagina what is going through the mind of
a woman you know where she's not going
to get up or she's not gonna say
something especially because this is
where I think for a lot of men it gets
confusing of saying well you know
clearly I think most men would say
that's [ __ ] up like that is totally
you know that is that is just not
allowable and so then if a woman and I
realize this puts the onus on women but
if she doesn't respond in that way then
you know what I mean and in
conversations with with girls on campus
and in many cases they're girls I mean
they're teenagers they're young they're
inexperienced what are they saying
well first I would say also in this
country we tend not to say no and try to
confront people right so a guy if the
situation is reversed you know he may be
into it if he's not into it he may not
say much either right or he may say I
have a girlfriend he may not stand up
and say no
right in that case there were other
people present in the room so she was
embarrassed because she didn't know how
to get out of the situation without
embarrassing herself let's remember that
a lot of women despite everything I've
said carry a lot of shame around sex
right so they have a problem expressing
themselves sexually this is just simply
a fact you know women are socialized
also to be polite particularly in a
sexual situation so she then has a bunch
of different things working against her
saying something I mean one woman that I
interviewed at Syracuse University
talked to me about why she was
you open about how she was promiscuous
she had had a lot of sex with different
people she didn't feel that she had been
raped but she felt she had been really
pressured by a bunch of different guys
who had maybe like pushed her head down
to give a [ __ ] or just kind of kind
of push her into sex where she just
really kind of wanted to go to sleep and
what she said is really why we need a
yes means yes standard she said it's not
that I didn't you know I didn't I didn't
really want to say no I wasn't totally
opposed but I was really really drunk
and I didn't want to have sex but I
wanted him to be satisfied and happy and
he said he had blue balls and I felt bad
about it but I never would have said yes
if he had said to me are you sure you
want to do this I never would have said
yes when it comes to statistics
available statistics about on-campus
assault rates these are always heavily
you know debated and argued in in the
media as well as even among so you know
among the people who actually collect
them and that's also you have a great
discussion of the the wide variety of
people all of whom are interested you
know it isn't like there are any pro
rapists in the demography world who are
like let's do this but you find you you
find you know numbers are you produce
numbers about unwanted sexual activity
that range from about 20 percent you
know that one in five students students
by the time they graduate college will
have had some kind of unwelcome sexual
advance or event to maybe seven percent
where the definition is much more kind
of specific and explicit about sexual
penetration or other acts of violence
against the body what is you know what
what is your best estimate or how do we
talk about that because the one in five
sometimes one in four number gets
bandied about and it seems that that may
kind of confuse as much as a Clara
thoughts right well I mean there's
nobody who works in the field of
demography who thinks that this is
enough is not a total mess right this is
a huge mess we don't have a good grasp
of how many college students are
sexually assaulted we only know by the
way what's happening at a specific
school and then we're extrapolating oh
that's a nation
number at a number of the studies I mean
early on that produced like pretty
pretty large numbers they were you talk
about this I mean a couple were just at
two schools people like David Lee sac
who created the serial predator model
it's very influential it's all based on
very non representatives cases yes yes
but I mean there's also a question of
should attempted assault be included
just because a girl went home with a guy
and she felt he was creepy and weird and
threw him out right she's not sure that
she was almost assaulted there right so
I think that probably shouldn't be
included and of course you know there's
not a lot of nuance there about
something like a groping versus a
violent penetrative rape where somebody
locks a door from the inside after
you've done a bunch of lines of cocaine
with that guy okay so those things need
to be separated out I don't believe that
we should separate out you know
penetration from non penetration but I
do think we need to separate out
violence from non violence right some
guy coming up behind you in a on a dance
floor and grinding on you is not
necessarily an act of violence right and
I think putting all of these things in
some big pot and stirring it around the
way a lot of activists have is just
really you know created one of the most
intense backlashes of misogyny that I
have seen in my lifetime so we need to
be very clear about our definitions
let's talk about the role of the media
and kind of hyping and distorting you
know this discussion I mean and it is a
society-wide discussion that every
generation has but particularly about
sex and assault on campus in many of the
highest profile cases going back a few
years to the Duke lacrosse team which
was charged with gang raping and that
fell apart and there was an outcry by
the Faculty of due to say even before
any kind of legal investigation had been
launched you know we got to get rid of
these people they shut down the lacrosse
program
turned out that the reality was very
very different than that there was
rolling stones story about a gang rape
at University of Virginia I mean
essentially ended you know with a
complete retraction of that story in the
events of that you know those are
completely discredited other less
clear-cut ones are one of the main
stories in the hunting ground a
documentary about sexual assault on
campus involved a black male law student
at Harvard who was accused of sexual
misconduct something like 19 law
professor said the hunter Graham
misrepresented the case and the facts of
the case in a pernicious way the sole
Kuwait's Nungesser case is more of a
kind of mirror by which we can see what
we feel rather than knowing what's going
on talk about the media's role like
obviously the media loves to talk about
this stuff because it's young kids it's
sex it's booze it is you know violence I
mean you know our I mean you you you
know great classic literature is all
about you know sex murder assault
violence is the great the media in the
discussion of this time yeah I mean the
media has been you know the the worst
actor in all this right because they're
only interested in cases that are
unbelievable they're interested in Duke
Lacrosse a bunch of Duke lacrosse
players at this fantastic University
rape to prostitutes right black white
guys raped by these white over
privileged southern males or UVA story
wasn't that different right a helpless
defenseless young girl went on a date to
this fraternity and in a pledge ritual
seven boys pushed her down on a glass
table which shattered beneath her and
they raped her one of them had a beer
bottle guy from her anthropology seminar
was there okay
these are unbelievable stories because
they're unbelievable because that's not
what's really happening there is not
gang rape going on as a pledge ritual at
UVA upstairs while a party is going
downstairs I'm not saying that never in
the history of you know fraternities in
America there hasn't been a pledge
ritual that has involved a rape but
these are certainly not the kinds of
things that are going on on campus
what's going on on campus
our questions about consent but that
becomes an abstract story and the media
doesn't know how to deal with that they
just want their it bleeds it leads it's
five o'clock local news and we're
talking about girls you need to be
scared because they're scary scary scary
predators coming after you on campus
while you walk to the library and is
that you know in in a sense reading your
book what what is both you know
fascinating to me about it is that it's
about this larger question of sexual
mores and which do change and you know
it just says you know we grew up in a
totally different sexual world than our
parents or we like to think that any way
our children grow up in a totally
different world so it's about that
larger conversation but then how do how
can the media represent you know they
don't like to because they want to talk
about cases that are clear-cut or that
stirred deep primordial you know fears
and anxieties and titillation you know
how what what is a way of representing
that conversation about like Stanford
and Columbia both of whom were hit real
hard on this sexual assault issue from
the pr's perspective have both been
promoting this idea of healthy sexuality
let's talk about sexual mores let's talk
about ethics let's begin to bring this
to a conversation that everybody can
contribute to so let's get away from
who's lying and who's telling the truth
let's get away from the unbelievable
story of rape and then of course in
America we love to debunk that story we
love to say women live immoral or we
love I mean you know this is another
thing that's fascinating the book and
you talk a little bit about
intersectionality and the way that it's
infusing feminism campus feminism there
is a really kind of ugly usually
unspoken unremarked upon race issue here
so the Vanderbilts story where I guess
it was three or four Vanderbilt football
players and black were found guilty of
raping a woman who had passed out and
they took pictures but it's blacks on
white and that also particularly a
school like Vanderbilt which is you know
in Nashville it's part of the South how
does that play out it
the racial issues or racial dynamics
well you know there you know certainly
our attorneys and you know the Atlantic
magazine has recently published a story
about this who anecdotally think that
there are more black kids at black boys
who are being accused of assault on
campus particularly by white women and
you know Jeannie Suk has had this idea
of like well maybe they the white woman
wakes up the next day and says well did
I just sleep with a black man well that
wouldn't be part of what how I see
myself as a sexual being I feel that
something went wrong there you know I'm
not sure I would really go that far I
will say that in football the gang rape
that is happening there is largely
happening with black players and it is
largely you know football players are
celebrities on campus they have groupies
they have girls who want to have sex
with them the real problem is that they
will have sex with one girl maybe the
girl will have sex with a football
player and a recruit right because I
gotta get the recruit laid when he comes
to college cuz otherwise he's not gonna
come there to play for them which is by
the way I mean let's not go for that
Rick Pitino the you know you know
legendary coach just got fired
basketball coach just got fired from
University of Louisville for you know
his role in allowing that type of be
sure I mean that is essentially kind of
the the origin of the Vanderbilt rape
case that's what happened with the
Golden Gophers in the University of
Minnesota that big case last year over
and over we see these cases where there
are girls who want to have sex with one
football player but they don't want to
have sex with the other ones you know
Jameis Winston case I don't know what
really happened there but you know that
could be a similar case remember there
was something going on with a girl in
Jameis Winston and his friends were able
to open the door and come in with cell
phone cameras what happened what was she
thinking right then and there you know
so these girls then are faced with these
you know like really pretty menacing
figures right and you know that that's
something we really need to deal with
that is a reality
in the book you talk a lot about sports
you know in its football players
basketball players in particular they I
mean it's not just in college that
they're celebrities they're accorded a
kind of privilege that very few people
do and they don't they you know one and
this may be stereotyping but they live
in a world where nobody says no to them
or where if they say no they don't hear
no also fraternities are you know the
site of a lot of this activity of the
most you know provocative and probably
emblematic cases you know is you know
are these things that need to be yeah I
mean the fraternities obviously should
not be on campus like I have no idea why
there's a title nine exemption for
single sex social groups I mean that
makes like it does they're not really on
campus right through there some of them
are off campus and you know the
universities are doing this big dance
with the fraternities and the legal
liability right but what's going on is
universities don't want the legal
liability from drinking from their
students they pushed the drinking
completely off campus you get caught
with a keg in your dorm you are in some
serious trouble today right we in the
90s I know yeah we kind of did it maybe
something got in trouble what I gotta
tell you the ladies you could actually
legally have those so it's a change so I
mean they you know my problem with the
frats is not obviously all frats are bad
but you know we know what's going on
here is about these kind of gender norms
and gender norms are reinforced by frats
obviously because you know one is
there's no women in there it just seems
to me like all this discussion of due
process for these tiny tiny number of
cases that happen across the country was
something like 6,000 cases in 2014
6,000 campus tribunals across the entire
country for sexual assault and yet we're
not talking about the fact that the
Greek system is up by half over the last
decade that there's more stringent
drinking going on binge drinking is
directly connected yeah let's talk about
on both sides actually and it's not it's
not to compute responsibility to a woman
but I mean and well let's talk about
that in the
context of your recommendations for how
to you know how to reduce sexual assault
and also how to have a healthier
conversation about sexual mores on
campus one of the main things that you
say is lower the drinking age to 18 you
know how does that address this issue
well the issue is is that you have young
people coming to college but a lot of
these sexual assaults are happening
right during September right right when
the kids get there and they don't have a
lot of them particularly about yeah yeah
I mean something like 88% of gang rape
victims according to a one insurer our
freshman right so they're coming there
they don't have a lot of experience with
drinking they're getting blasted out of
their mind so they may be in a blackout
and they're agreeing to sexual activity
that they wouldn't normally now you
might say well that's that's your
individual responsibility to deal with
that and an activist may say well
according to the patriarchy the girl who
gets really drunk will think she needs
to service a guy if she gets into a
sexual experience with him I'm not
saying either of those things although
you would agree I mean Emily Yaffe a
writer at when it's late she when she in
an article said you know you know women
if you want to if you want to avoid
really horrible situations it's a good
idea not to get shit-faced right she was
called a rape denial as my people at met
you know websites like Jezebel hustle I
mean clearly that's [ __ ] up right I
mean to say yes no I agree I mean I know
I don't agree with a lot of what Emily
off you is saying but I do agree with
her there that you know alcohol is a
problem here that young women binge
drinking is up for women has been for a
while and what the issue is is that like
you can drink in moderation girls that
use no problem but there's research
showing that over nine drinks you are at
a higher risk for sexual assault now
over nine drinks is an obscene amount of
alcohol for a 19 year old girl right so
there's nothing about being in a
blackout or passing out at a house an
off-campus house even maybe even in your
dorm with a bunch of guys that you don't
know that is safe there's nothing about
that's it but it's also then what what
is is do you think the attitudes are
changing that you know if you're one of
the guys in that house and there's an
unconscious body absolutely is it
changing that I mean I obviously this
happens I struggle to understand it
where any would be like anyone would be
like that's an invitation even to take a
horrifying photo much less actually
acting on right is the reason to believe
that boys are getting better yeah we
don't have any hard data on if the
assaults are going down and everything's
being muddied by this broadening
definition of assault so now you have
girls counting themselves as victims
that maybe would enough five years ago I
mean as I said before it is a total mess
so we're not gonna get hard data on that
but in my conversations with guys
anecdotally there is no question that to
be a cool guy and I'm talking about
Brown University and I'm talking about
cool campuses I mean like the University
of Michigan corners of that campus
places like that but to be a cool guy
and a guy that girls want to date you
must at least give lip service to these
ideas you must at least in your words be
Pro survivor and if you're gonna do
something like mess with a drunk girl
you better make sure that their other
aren't other guys there who are gonna go
around the next day and tell girls that
you did that because the girls will
ostracize you now you also in one of
your recommendations at towards the end
of the book you do say for people who
are accused they call a lawyer and why
why is it yeah I mean look being accused
of sexual assault at college is you know
the pretty much the worst thing that can
happen to you at college right
you pulled the unlucky story you'll pull
the short straw it happened to you you
know this there there's no good outcome
right like either you're gonna go
through a horrible tribunal and you're
gonna come out relatively unscathed but
everybody on campus is gonna think
you're a rapist or you're gonna get
kicked out of school and you're gonna be
humiliated in front of your family and
you may not be able to get into a school
of comparable value with blah blah blah
blah I mean you know it's kind of like a
divorce there's only losers here right
right so you must call a lawyer you must
call your parents
right away I cannot tell you how many
boys I talked to who didn't call their
parents because they were embarrassed
they thought I'm an adult I can handle
this oh the school the school that I I
wanted so badly to get into this school
I loved this school I have a bumper
sticker of the school they never do
anything to hurt me right no no no that
is not the case you were in a serious
situation go back to the title nine
guidance the Office of Civil Rights the
Dear Colleague letter what that reduced
the standard of of evidence in in camps
tribunals or you know it administrative
hearings and you've talked about how
they've changed but it went from using a
traditional clear and convincing
standard which was a higher burden of
proof that something bad happened to
what was called a preponderance of
evidence senator that holds that it's
more likely than not that sexual
harassment occurred and in your book you
talk about how that's kind of like it's
50/50 and then the feather gets put on
the guilty is it a good thing to get rid
of that because that does seem odd you
know particularly in a in a kind of
hearing that it you know mimics legal
legal due process but and you know is
that where does that fit in because
you're actually in favor of the lower
level right how do you how do you
justify that okay well first of all you
know like eighty percent of campuses
were already using the preponderance of
evidence before Obama got involved here
so it is a bit of a myth that you know
clear and convincing was true all over
the place you know the fact is that as I
said before sexual assault is incredibly
hard to prove coming up with that 1% to
push it to 51% is a lot harder than you
think
right and if we raise the burden of
proof what I believe will happen is you
will have a lot of middle-aged
administrators that are already carrying
their own biases they will say wait a
second
so this girl sexting a picture to this
guy five hours before this alleged
assault ray cheese she sent him a
picture of her boobs well I mean why do
we even care what happened after that
the next day
very often girls will text the guy the
next day and say listen you know I had a
good time last night but some stuff
happened that I feel weird about
you can you give me a call could we meet
up oh yeah you know emoji heart heart
heart I mean these are these are young
girls you know they're trying to get the
guy to talk to them to try to understand
what happened last night I feel I feel
violated by that can we talk about this
right I mean under a clear and
convincing standard are those boys gonna
be punished
I just from finding that very hard to
believe so just from a pragmatic point
of view but what if that means so if I
mean it's one you know and it's one
thing to say after something something
I'm not uncomfortable with something
let's talk about that as opposed to
oftentimes the text message is you know
and this is even in the sole Kuwait's
case where there were you know there was
communications after the alleged assault
you know where it was not she wasn't
saying hey something weird happened she
did say well in song she did say that in
some look I'm not gonna say that the
text message is between the two of them
aren't damning because I know what I did
Sam I want to talk to you and remember
they I'm not sure they ever got together
to talk about it right they both knew
that something happened that night he
wasn't totally blindsided he knew
something it happened she didn't I guess
in terms of the preponderance of
evidence of what you know what if you
know 50 I mean it's gone 51% isn't the
right you know marker of guilt or or
that something happened I mean we're
gonna see because certainly universities
are gonna go back to clear and
convincing some place like Harvard ISM
all the religious institutions are going
to do that and well you know in this
race is a related question which is and
in talking with Camille Polly about this
she said you know you know and she
obviously she's you know a baby-boomer
sexual empowerment feminist I mean when
you talk it you know when you talk about
people like Madonna or Katy Perry or
Kesh or whatnot they're all kind of
they're standing in the shadow
you know Camille Holly has thrown on
certain levels she says one of the
biggest problems and this fits in a way
with your book you know part of the
problem here is why are colleges you
know doing things about students like
why do they have dorms why are they in
the personal lives of students
one of the things one of the themes in
your book is that most of this stuff you
know we call a campus rape but virtually
none of it actually happens on the
campus it's almost always partly because
you have to drink off campus so people
live off campus so they can drink you go
to parties off campus how does that play
into you know this larger conversation I
mean the conversation we need to have
and that that you know parents and
students and people are starting to have
is what the hell is college for anyway
right like here we are all of these kids
on a campus for four years no
responsibility really no genuine
academic interests hell of a lot of
leisure time a lot of time to be on the
phone hang out with your pals hang out
with your girls you know is this an
etiquette Factory is it a career making
fun it's a finishing school or a holding
time and now that adulthood has like
continues to thirty like do you know do
we really need this four-year period
where parents are going broke trying to
send their kids to do what exactly so I
think that anybody involved in
universities today knows that we're in a
bubble it's gonna pop and you know my
children may not be going to anything
that resembles a Vanderbilt University
right well and you know that's to drive
home the the point of your book which is
that this conversation is happening and
that you know you we can have a better
more open or less up and a more
conscious or less conscious conversation
I mean part of it is to have a
conversation with if you're going away
to college to actually talk with your
parents you stress them one of your
recommendations is don't hurry over the
actual sexual consent policy and
everybody's Student Handbook what what
will we find if we actually read yeah I
mean look New York Connecticut
California Illinois all of these states
have for all public and private colleges
I guess means yes standard so no means
no is not enough silence is not consent
you must get some sort of you know
feedback from the partner now for Gen
Xers and even maybe boomers the question
was like should I get a condom right and
that was really a question about
protection and permission it was a
question where
you know the guy would usually ask it
and the girl or the guy could say no
because we're not having sex actually
you know now you know there's protection
being used sometimes but also there
seems to beat me a need to be this
additional question of are we ready
which is a question that high schoolers
ask their first girlfriends or
boyfriends right are we ready to do this
but yet two years later it's all cool
and not a word needs to be uttered in
the bedroom right I think the parents
will find that they don't even need to
have a conversation about sex with their
college student all they need to do is
flip through their college handbook you
know the Ivy League's have this many
state universities have this and just
say wow this is a yes means yes standard
this says like it's if sexual misconduct
and it's clear that that's not going
because people aren't recording this
although I mean you you mentioned in
passing that there are apps and things
like that now this gets to a kind of
almost like Kurt Vonnegut level satire
of like okay at this point in and you
know and then maybe you can punish
people if the orgasm isn't good at
cetera but so it's not going to clear up
the confusion or it's not going to
completely deep blur the lines but it it
will prove I mean your argument is that
it will provide a better context of
social pain I mean people who understand
why sexual assault happens best you know
the people who teach this the older
women who have really studied this from
a social psychological perspective
really want girls to know that what they
need to do is remove themselves from the
situation first don't go home with the
random guy after the frat party who's
like hey we should go back to my
apartment because I got some beer there
just come with me come on you know don't
do it because once you get there you're
gonna have a hard time getting out of it
for the reasons I explained before in
terms of that you're not gonna say no
when you're not gonna realize it's
happening you're like slow on the uptake
well maybe I'll just do it because I
might as well just do it and get it over
with or I'm afraid he might hurt me he
seems a lot bigger all of those
questions could be placed aside if a
question was asked and I am comfortable
with saying once that question is asked
and a woman says yes I'm comfortable
then calling some of that stuff
consensual sex right because then it's
her responsibility she said yes reason
is a libertarian organization and what
we you know one of the things that is is
a bedrock kind of touchstone in
libertarianism is the idea of autonomy
and I think one of the things I found
really appealing about your book is this
discussion of consent and of self
ownership do your best to spin why for a
libertarian specifically a libertarian
audience why consent is the central
issue of kind of the Millennial general
right sure so you know if I want your
wallet I have to say hey can I have your
wallet right and then you give it to me
I can't take it I can't take really
anything in this world without asking
for permission first but in sex for some
reason everything's cool everybody our
our legal philosophy is everybody in
America is agreeing to have sex with
everybody else until somebody says no
right I mean does that really make a lot
of sense you know certainly there should
be sexual autonomy and bodily autonomy
for young girls whose bodies really are
pretty manhandled in this world and who
deal with a lot of guys who want to
touch them right they have something
valuable so they're demanding that they
get a question first and then give
consent I think that's super simple you
know all right well we will leave a
thing yeah we've been talking with
Vanessa grigory artists she is the
author of the new book blurred lines
rethinking sex power and consent on
campus Vanessa thanks so much thank you
so much for reason I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]